[موسيقى]
استعدادات المنتخب الوطني المغربي ياسر
السعديه لان الكل يعرفوا الاسبانيه الكل
يعرف منتخب اسبانيا الكل يعرف اللاعب الذي
يلعبون في اسبانيا ان المغرب مقسومه على
اثنين من ريال مدريد و برشلونه
[موسيقى]
كل لاعبي المنتخب الوطني المغربي بخصوص
الاساسين ومحترفون خارج ارض الوطن باوروبا
صحيح ان اللاعبين الواهدين واللاعب ليس
يستفيدون من خبره لهيب المحترفين ولكن
المنتخب المغربي اليوم
محترفين في اوروبا من الحارس الى المهاجم
فرص تاهيل المنتخب السويسريه قائمه 50 50
لا ننسى ان المنتخب السوري
في مرات كثيره وبالتالي لما يلتف يلتقي
الفريقين في مجموعه
تكون دائما المباريات قويه وقويه جدا
وبالتالي لا يجب السهام للمنتخب السويس
الا دي يضمه في في صفوفه لاعبين همم ديال
كسوه ديال اليوسفيه السابقه
يعني قوه
تقنيات كبيره
المنتخب
البرتغالي بكام الصفوف في منتخب قوي ما
هذا رونالدو يضم لاعبين كبار بالعالم
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]